[Music]
a very good evening time then for
sunday's press preview checking out
tomorrow's front pages and tonight we'll
see what's making the headlines with
jake wally simons editor of the jewish
chronicle and leslie riddick journalist
and broadcaster good evening to you
we'll chat in a moment after we've had a
look at the bank holiday papers starting
with the eye as the cost of living
crisis worsens the paper reports that
liz truss is coming under growing
pressure to widen the range of help
she's prepared to offer if she becomes
prime minister
a times poll finds half of tory voters
want energy to be nationalized as the
crisis deepens
the telegraph meanwhile carries a call
from boris johnson not to give up on
investing in green energy in favor of
short-term fixes to tackle the cost of
living
crisis while the express piles on the
misery with a prediction from poverty
campaigners that millions of people will
be cut adrift from the financial system
within five years if the use of cash is
phased out
is the ft reporting that central banks
around the world are worried that we
have the most uncertain economic
landscape for decades and that tackling
high inflation could be a problem for
years
while the guardian has been looking at
nhs waiting lists and has found that
black and asian cancer patients are
having to wait longer for cancer
diagnosis
the star derived suggestions by the head
of the environment agency that we should
drink recycled lu water to avoid
shortages after the hot summer
and a reminder that by scanning the qr
code you'll see on screen during the
program you can check out the front
pages of monday's papers while you watch
and listen to us and i'm joined tonight
by jake wallace simons editor for the
jewish chronicle and leslie journalist
and broadcast of a happy bank holiday
weekend uh to both of you uh leslie why
don't we start things off with the front
page of the times
and this extraordinary headline half of
tory voters
want energy to be nationalized
it's extraordinary isn't it really
amazing um anyway it's a yougov poll
that um obviously the times have got
commissioned for them so they've got the
story to themselves
it shows that 47 of tory voters are for
taking energy back into public ownership
with just 28 percent against 25 percent
don't know
and further on in that
poll that hugo have done they've asked
whether people trust trusts
so difficult one to say and they find um
on on conquering inflation that only uh
13
one presumes a gain of tory voters
think that liz trust can can deal with
inflation 70 percent don't
well it's very interesting that um
leslie isn't it because uh presumably if
you just spoke to uh the people who are
going to choose the next prime minister
then the results will be very different
yes it is weird isn't it because
actually uh they've they've even
fine-tuned that that result darn to look
at
people who voted conservative in the
2019 election particularly in the red
wall seats and you find then that 53
percent of those people want energy not
renationalized so
this when you look at as well we might
come on to it but you know general
generally a bit of support actually for
striking particularly rail workers with
the
pretty charismatic figure of mick lynch
at the front um shaping up an opposition
really to whoever wins this contest in a
week and a bits time
it's really taking on a much much bigger
fight for the shape of britain to come
and it's not at all clear that the the
party leaders have actually got the
answers um that that even their own
supporters want yeah i mean it is
fascinating times were in jake not only
the political
landscape changing but the the very way
that um
that the uk has been run for a very long
time and what do you make of this times
headline
well it's an extremely striking headline
um and
i think it's tempting to draw the
conclusion that tories have become
socialists but i think that that isn't
necessarily the case i think the problem
is that people
are hurting at the moment
we know that the energy prices are
spiraling they're creating real pain for
everyday people at all levels of income
frankly um and we've been presented
basically over the last you know few
decades with two options one is to have
complete nationalization and the other
is the privatization that came in under
the thatcher government and neither are
working and at the moment we're
suffering the pain that's coming under
privatization and so people naturally
will want to go back to how it was
before
but the the the problem is that neither
really have worked and what we really
need is something that's going to avoid
monopoly in the markets and at the
moment the companies are so big that
they're an effective monopoly and so the
the uh the leveling out uh effects of
competition is not working properly and
that is at the the sort of fundamental
point that's causing uh such high prices
for consumers and such pain in terms of
the um the services that we receive such
as things like almost 25 of water
leaking out of the system i mean this is
unacceptable to people really i mean
leslie um
in a way whether you nationalize uh the
energy companies or not the the
fundamental problem isn't going to
change is it the wholesale price of
energy has got to be paid for whether
it's by the government or the private
sector
and that is the thing because uh you
know nationalizing the big six or uh
whatever might be left of them within a
few months is is really not the big
story the big big profits are being made
by bp and shell the actual oil and gas
producers out in the north sea and there
the story is is also a difficult one
because uh there is no gas storage in
britain that was sold off in 2017 2018
because the investment was needed the
government turned down the private
company that asked for help to increase
its gas storage so as a result we set
our sending our north sea gas through to
mature democracies clever countries
who've got gas storage in the continent
they store it and then we buy it back
from them so you know there's
if certainly the private the private
ownership of what in many other
countries has been kept in public hands
just seems to be now reaching its end
date
jake it's a it's a similar theme on the
front of the financial times utilities
and regulators not fit for purpose
says one government or ex-government
advisor
that's right this is simply reflecting
the the view that we've both been
expressing that currently
uh the uh the monopoly uh enjoyed by the
utility companies and the energy
companies uh is is is wearing a little
bit thin as the price cap is going up
and up and up leaving consumers with no
option
but to shell out these vast sums um and
uh and in some cases go bankrupt in the
first place but leslie's right i mean
our
storage capacity in the uk is not what
it should be uh and in our pursuit of a
net zero target in 2050 we've left our
energy uh ecosystem hugely fragile
buying in energy from overseas liquefied
natural gas from qatar for example uh
meaning that our supply lines are
fragile and we're not producing enough
of our own energy we've been turning
away from fracking turning away from
north sea oil exploration and turning
away from the nuclear solution as well
and all of this has got to be turned
around to form a proper uk energy policy
and unfortunately under the current
pressure that's not going to happen
anytime soon well let's have a look at
the front of the daily telegraph then
leslie because boris johnson is uh set
to be to to give a speech where he says
that we can still pursue
net zero uh whilst also helping people
with uh with their heating bills
and clearly this is going to be
something at the top of the agenda for
whoever goes into number 10 and
certainly we know liz trust has got
quite strong ideas uh along these lines
well yes uh boris is apparently going to
say that basically don't don't dump dump
the idea of shifting to green energy um
that don't do short-term fixes of course
we know that uh both rishi sunak and les
tras are committed to dumping the green
levy um so
it sounds as if boris is weighing in as
one of her his very last uh gestures or
speeches as prime minister to basically
question the merits of both of those now
you'd have to think that actually on
this even though i would have a bit of
an argument about nuclear energy
particularly in scotland where hydro
provides us with an awful lot of base
load energy that's the kind you can
switch on and off fast
whether you want to be going down the
road of looking for more
oil and gas or whether you really want
to be pushing renewable energy we've
just had a sea green massive massive
wind farm it's one of the deepest wind
farms in the world opened off the coast
just beside me here near dundee
we need one of those to be built
practically every year from now to 2030
to hit boris johnson's targets now
that's what has to be done it's also job
creation and it's a total shift away
from dependency on gas which is what's
given britain the terrible price hikes
that haven't been experienced in other
countries
jake
yes i mean i think nobody denies the uh
the fact that we've got to go green in
the longer term
and that will become easier and easier
we hope as the years go by and
technology improves um and green energy
becomes a more fulfilling uh source of
energy for our for our household needs
and our national needs however the
problem is that by setting this rigid
target of 2050 our energy security has
been sacrificed uh meaning that we've
ended up buying in fossil fuel
from overseas while denigrating our own
production of fossil fuel well it still
comes out of the planet somewhere um and
so i think that both richard zunak and
liz trust have got the right idea in
looking at this sensibly putting our
energy security first
looking at net zero obviously as a
target but not allowing the ideology of
getting there quickly to compromise our
own security and the consumer's benefit
in the short term leslie i'm going to
let you come back on this because i can
see you shaking your head
well well i totally am i mean the
ideology is the idea that you get any
benefit out of any more drilling in the
north sea all you do with more drilling
in the north sea is bump up the profits
of bp and shell to an extra couple of
billion pounds because they
sell their gas on the international
commodity market instead of being a
resource for the british people
okay all right we'll leave that there
and move on to a different story it's on
the front of the guardian again a
desperately depressing uh headline jake
revealed black and asian cancer patients
wait longer for diagnosis
that's right and the uh the findings are
very worrying indeed essentially that
white people
wait for an average of 55 days for a
diagnosis over the last 10 years or so
this study has been done
whereas asian people wait for i think
it's 60 days and black people for 61
days and this is obviously alarming and
appalling and something which must be
rectified as soon as possible but the
problem is that the question that the
guardian isn't answering or that
researchers are not answering is why is
this happening on the one hand this
could be happening because of endemic
racism so when a black or asian person
comes to the to the doctor they're not
treated the same as a white person and
the nhs is institutionally racist or it
could be that other factors are at play
as well for example socio-economic
factors that more black or asian people
live in poor
parts of the country and so on and so
forth but this study has been done
purely through the prism of race and so
it lends itself to this
race-based headline which raises more
questions than it actually answers and
that's my concern about this story yeah
it's an excellent term exclusive by
their health editor andrew gregory and
it's based on the findings of
a huge survey 126 thousand cancer cases
leslie i mean i mean
it it it sort of beggars belief
it does and it's uh that that huge
number
of cases have been analyzed over a
period of a decade
and they're looking at six to seven
cancers particularly and finding that
over the piece black and asian patients
wait six weeks more
i mean i actually totally agree with
jake that you're left at the end of this
and of course perhaps if we delve
further in the paper we'd see more but
just wondering
what this could be put down to and and
presumably some um experts and analysts
will have been asked for their opinions
on this because this cannot have come
out of the blue there's been similar
problems when it comes to donating blood
differential differential rates of
donation from black and asian people and
which has been highlighted recently so
is there something that makes people
it's the same with working class people
they're late to present men like to
present there's all sorts of groups
within society who put off that moment
of going to the doctor but then again
we've just come through a covert period
where it's been impossible to get to a
doctor for many people so
it's hard to know from this what really
lies at the back of this yeah always
difficult isn't it in the paper review
when you only get the front pages to
know exactly uh where the story goes uh
perhaps there'll be more explanation
when we get the full copy of the
guardian a bit later for now thank you
both very much indeed more papers on the
way including this story it's on the
front of monday's telegraph sussex's may
miss queen amid dispute over security
discussing that more in a couple months
[Music]
welcome back part two of the press
preview jake and leslie still with us
jake front page of the daily telegraph
talk to us about the queen and whether
she's going to get to see harry and
megan
well i think it's really a case of
whether harry and megan will get to see
the queen isn't it i mean they're coming
to uh to britain for a visit
and they're in this weird sort of
halfway house position which is they're
still
members of the royal family they have
their titles but they're not working
members of the royal family and for some
years ever since this happened this
shift happened in 2020 there's been a
dispute about the about who pays for
their security so previously when they
were working members of the royal family
the you know the met police would
provide it but now that's not quite so
clear
um and there's even been legal illegal
tussle taking place over the couple over
a couple years between
harry and the met police and the
authorities here about who will pay for
it for his security and that seems to
have got in between his plans and
negative plans for going to see the
queen in bound moral when they come to
visit which would be a great shame
because you know who knows how many more
times he will get the opportunity to see
the queen um and everybody wants them to
be able to have a normal family life and
it's a great shame that his and megan's
move away from the royal family in this
way
has had this this sort of repercussion
okay i'm going to rattle on uh because
we want to get through a couple more
stories before uh the end of the hour
leslie so talk to me about this story in
the daily express i mean these numbers
are incredible i think probably partly
down to the the the incredible weather
we've been having over the summer but 25
000 small boat migrants so far this year
yes um and again this is exactly in the
opposite direction of what was promised
by pretty much every candidate within
the tory leadership they're all
very much pushing on to
trying to close down what they say are
it's a trafficking operation that's
absolutely obviously the case but uh the
the idea that the threat of being
deported to rwanda would actually deter
any of these people from coming over in
the first place just doesn't seem to be
happening and of course every time we
see that there's yet another natural
disaster or economic disaster which
we're seeing in pakistan with an
unbelievable 33 million people being
apparently displaced by the floods there
this will feed its way through to yet
more movements and people desperate to
come to countries that seem more stable
so
we're going to have to try to tackle
this and it's quite clear that the
current way of approaching it just isn't
working
jake your thoughts
yeah i'm not sure i agree with that
analysis i mean the reason why the
rwanda plan failed to deter migrants
from coming over that it was kibosh by
uh lawyers and left-wing activists who
took the government to court and made
meant that only one person in the end
was cleared to go and even that didn't
happen and so of course it's not going
to be a deterrent if that's what happens
um i think that the people it's
important to recognize that the people
who are attempting to come over are
coming over from france not from
pakistan they're not in a place of
danger in france in calais i mean i've
met many of these people over the years
of being a foreign reporter on the road
and
and the vast majority of them uh do not
have a legitimate asylum claim and
certainly not from france and so this is
on the whole illegal
migration into the uk recently it's been
mainly albanians that have been coming
over there were 900 just today
coming over from france and the
government does need to take a tough
tough measures to deter this very
dangerous attempt across the channel
which only funds people trafficking and
crime and goes into the pockets of
people who cause a lot of suffering to a
lot of people
okay i just want to finish um on this
story about nasa on the front of the
daily telegraph we know the artemis
mission wants to send humans to the moon
once again but nasa is looking further
ahead leslie
it is and i mean in the one hand i
suppose everybody's desperately looking
for some sort of sense that the future
is more optimistic that we are boldly
going where we haven't gone before and
that there's there's some uh
essentially scientific push to try to
to to get back to those glory days i
suppose which people might remember of
all the apollo missions um so that that
feels good that that kind of uh that
kind of push is still going on and yet
it sits so weirdly actually with
everything we've talked about tonight
where there's just doesn't seem to be
the cash across the globe pretty much to
be funding that kind of scientific
mission yeah sometimes it does look like
things might be more pleasant living on
the moon or on the mars thank you both
very much indeed